la gráfica de igualados elevado a la x
se muestra abajo y aquí tenemos
justamente esa gráfica nos preguntan
cuál de las siguientes es la gráfica de
ye igual a 3 x 2 a la x menos cuatro más
2 muy bien y aquí tenemos nuestras
cuatro opciones de la cual habrá que
elegir algún entonces vayamos viendo
poco a poco cómo es que está descrita la
gráfica de esta función entonces primero
pensemos en la parte de 2 a la x menos 4
y igualados elevado a la equis menos
cuatro y básicamente lo que estamos
haciendo aquí es trasladar la gráfica
que tenemos de igualados a la x cuatro
unidades a la derecha fíjense cuando x
vale 4 el exponente vale 0 que es
justamente como cuando estamos aquí
verdad entonces este sería nuestro
primer punto cuando x vale 5 es justo
cuando el exponente de la moralidad vale
1 que es dos verdades si todos elevado a
las 5 menos 4 sería 2 a la 1 que es 2
verdad entonces más o menos estaría aquí
y sólo 1 último cuando x es igual a 66
menos cuatro es 22 elevado a la 2 es 4
verdad entonces si nos damos cuenta
básicamente lo que estamos haciendo es
trasladar la gráfica cuatro unidades a
la derecha en cada uno
sus puntos entonces más o menos esto se
verá algo así estoy tratando deja de
hacerlo lo mejor que puedo para que se
vea cómo es que toda esta gráfica
simplemente la trasladamos cuatro
unidades a la derecha muy bien ahora qué
pasa con ye igual a tres veces 2 a la x
menos 4 bueno cada uno de estos puntos
habrá que multiplicarlos por 3 verdad
por ejemplo aquí vale 1 entonces ahora
vale 3
aquí vale 2 ahora vale 6
aquí vale 4 entonces ahora valdrá mucho
verdad que sería como 2 entonces
básicamente lo que estamos haciendo es
como es crear esta nueva gráfica
más o menos se ve así
hay caps ahí lo tienen es la gráfica
azul y ahora qué es lo que vamos a hacer
con la parte de +2 verdad aquí estamos
sumándole dos entonces consideremos de
igual a tres por dos a la x menos cuatro
más dos y al sumar dos lo único que
estamos haciendo lo único que estamos
haciendo es trasladar la gráfica azul
dos unidades hacia arriba entonces
equivalía a tres ahora vale 5
si aquí valía 6 ahora vale 8 y fíjense
muy bien todas las gráficas anteriores
tenían una cinta horizontal en cero así
que ahora vamos a obtener una a sin
total horizontal en dos verdad así que
más que nada esto se ve
así verdad más o menos es es más o menos
la idea verdad esencialmente es la
gráfica azul pero trasladada hacia
arriba dos unidades verdad entonces ya
que tenemos hecho esto vamos a ver qué
pasa con nuestras opciones entonces
definitivamente podríamos descartar la
opción a porque no crece hacia la
derecha y también la opción c cual de la
opción b y de la opción d sería bueno
ambas tienen asiento está horizontal en
dos cuando x tiende a menos infinito
pero podemos ver su valor en cuatro
verdad el valor en cuatro de la gráfica
roja es justamente 5 verdad y ésta si
cumple esa opción pero la opción de en 4
vale 3 entonces la opción de tenemos que
descartar la y nos quedamos con la
opción b